the Joe Rogan experience so I'm gonna
describe to you an extraordinary fact
about water and why we're alive today
okay so watch let's take a lake that has
fish in it okay temperature drops
outside and the lake slowly begins to
get cooler because there's a tent time
lag between the air temperature and the
waters that's why the first freeze the
lake is still there
it's got to be called longer all right
so what happens the water gets cold on
the surface okay and it begins to okay
the water gets cold on a surface and it
begins to shrink so that water falls
this shrink that makes a denser it falls
to the bottom fine it does that down to
about four degrees Celsius as it goes
from 43 Celsius to zero degrees Celsius
the freezing point it begins to expand
and become less dense than the water so
now as the water wants to actually
freeze it stays on top when it does
freeze you freeze the top surface of the
lake well how about the water below it
it's insulated from the dropping air
temperature and the fish don't die
imagine if ice were denser than water
what would happen you'd freeze the top
layer it would sink the bottom is frozen
freeze the next layer it sinks and fish
would be systematically forced to swim
in shallower and shallower waters until
they were all freeze dried on the top
surface of the lake and all fishes would
be dead every winter I think it's every
Lake thing it's fish
what I think you supposed to say fishes
fishes is a double plural you could do
that yeah you know fish would be dead
you know my ball dear would you say all
deers well cuz you generally it's one if
you had multiple kinds of deer yeah so
if you had like yeah but but but it's
rare that they're all in the same place
you generally have one kind of generally
but that the ocean has many kind of fish
in the same place oh yeah that's
interesting so you'd say fishes fishes
it's like it's a double floor it's
different kinds of plural fish
yeah double blow my mind look you know
you know it again oh no no no and if it
shows the many fishes in the oh yeah
yeah so sorry she's in the sea yeah so
multiple plurals of different to get
we're ocean water freezes boys salty
salt water do you have the word fishes
up there some weird anomaly that
happened where there was two or two
little oxygen in the water and somehow
the frozen fish got pushed out in a wall
of ice South Dakota so there's too
little oxygen I don't know I can't
explain that over there if you look at
if you look at the green in the water
most likely it's algae so that happens
with certain lakes that get polluted
with certain types of a you can kill the
lake but by doing that yeah well you get
it in the ocean to get these zones but I
don't see how you get frozen fish though
that's incredible but stop go back up
yeah scroll down so we could read it
fish frozen a wall of ice and South
Dakota's Lake Andes National Wildlife
Refuge that's incredible man is that a
video Jaime yeah I don't know how they
froze because they can just swim to
where it's not frozen so I'd have to do
more homework on that one to see what
what caused that Wow yeah so my point is
because of this property of water that
ice floats it insulates the bottom
layers of the lake and fish can survive
over the winter that's work too right
insulate so you can inside to get a look
at nah yeah sure yeah yeah I mean if you
put a barrier between you and the
changing elements outside that's
basically an insulating layer ice
fishing no I never never a good wife
person go ice fishing I'm sure in sense
what do women go ice fishing to get away
from their husbands they do yeah
why do people golf you know ice fishing
is particularly weird because you have
to continually scoop out the ice and
maybe even drill again right so that
works because frozen water is less dense
than non frozen water and it's one of
the rare ingredients for which that so
and it's likely there would be no life
on land or anywhere on earth if that
were the case if the opposite of that
were the case so water is a very special
ingredient
runner
[Applause]